with Stargate teetering on the edge of
pre-production me and Jay gonna argue
whether or not we need a movie or a TV
series first I'm of the opinion that we
need a TV series before any kind of
movie is even considered
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
before we get into this video I'd like
to invite you to join our Discord server
with over a hundred people in there
we're already talking about their
favorite science fiction television
shows from Stargate to Battlestar
Galactica and more
join the conversation now by heading to
dsc.gg forward slash Sidetrack or check
the links in the description this is
once again another head-to-head video
between me and Jay arguing a point about
Stargate and today we're going to be
arguing whether or not you need a TV
series or a movie to Kickstart a new
franchise I think you need a TV series
because although there are many valid
reasons why you would have a movie first
I think the reasons for a TV series
largely outweigh anything you can come
up with for a movie franchise actually
needs a movie to kick-start it it needs
the impact of a cinematic release and
even though it might be risky
the franchise needs it to be successful
let's take a look at the history of
Stargate first of all we have the
original 1994 movie uh created by Roland
Emerick and Dean Devlin and it was a
huge success no one can deny that
[Music]
thank you
it was that movie that gave birth to
Stargate SG-1 and subsequently Stargate
Atlantis and Stargate Universe I would
argue that the TV series is way more
important than what the movie ever was
yes the movie was fantastic yes it
kick-started the franchise but
I would argue you could have the TV
series as a standalone not even have the
original 1994 movie everything would
still make sense
and it would still be as popular that is
to say that the Stargate franchise was
literally built on the TV series itself
talking about and comparing a possible
new movie to the original Stargate movie
though is misleading whatever movie we
get it's not going to be the same but
let's not forget that it took a movie to
kick-start this franchise
that the Stargate SG-1 we know and love
would not have existed without that
original movie
so maybe to get it going again we need
another movie
we'll ask you on first aired it took
many of The Inspirations from the
original movie and it changed a few of
the things as well for the better
look at the main antagonists of the
movie ra he was as what we know to be a
grow old now but in the movie it was
never really established what he wants
in fact what he was portrayed as was an
alien inhabiting a body but kind of in a
way that made it look like he was
actually morphing into a human rather
than being a snake like being in the
back of the head as a parasite now sg1
basically adapted it and turned it into
the fact that the world is a parasitical
race of beings that go into a human host
and control the body
whereas RA in the original movie was
literally an alien as soon as he blew up
we saw his true form and that is
completely different to what we've seen
in the TV series
[Music]
I think that was a fantastic change and
it added so much more depth and a load
more stories that could be told with
that antagonist just look at the trial
of chlorell and Scara it brought in a
whole new argument of who is really in
control whose body is it
one of my favorite go Awards Lord
zapakner was arguing the fact that the
goal wool are just like we're taking the
body of an inferior being and we're
using it for our own purposes so who
really owns that body until three years
ago these humans on aberdos lived
undergo our old law
administered by Raw
Now by that law they would go at all
property Lord clorell nearly took what
was already his by force we also learned
within that storyline that something of
the host does survive give ingredients
to Daniel Jackson's fight for trying to
find his wife charae trying to free her
from her prison see the thing is with a
movie
I understand the argument that it could
kick-start the franchise in a really big
way there are arguments to be made that
if you make a movie it might be a huge
spectacle that it will get people
interested in Stargate once again but I
would argue that the interest for
Stargate never really went away and if a
TV series came out it would be just as
popular as it was when it was on back in
the day just take a look at this YouTube
channel Stargate has been off the air
for over a decade now and every time we
make a Stargate related video it gets so
many views so many people flock to the
comment section to to to to basically
shout out to Amazon and MGM that we want
Stargate back we want a continuation we
don't want any hard reboots the Stargate
fan base is still alive still kicking
still very very passionate
about a TV show that for all intents and
purposes has not been on the air for
over a decade if you were to create a
movie before a series then you're gonna
have a problem and that problem is
you're going to need to appeal to a much
wider audience
which means you can have to explain over
15 years worth of story with sg1 SGA and
SGU
to get them up to speed it is an issue
that there's a big gap between the
series and the movie but the movie
doesn't have to explain everything it
can just be a fun two-hour film that
sets up a load of questions that can
then be answered in the series because
don't forget the movie is not just a
one-off it is something that will lead
into a series something that will lead
into a franchise there is of course the
argument that I've just made that the
Stargate fans are still around the
kicking there are loads of us there were
literally millions of us in a recent
poll with 1.3 million people Stargate
sg1 was rated number four in the best
science fiction television shows of all
time so there is already a built-in
audience for a movie there but knowing
production companies and knowing people
like Amazon and MGM and things like that
they're going to want to appeal to a
newer audience a much younger audience
who are going to carry the franchise
forward for the next 10 20 years however
long they want to do it and that is an
issue because trying to explain three
seasons worth a television show
and make a movie make sense is
incredibly difficult I think what they
should be doing instead is focusing on
what we didn't get with the television
series so that would be a conclusion to
Stargate Atlantis because last time we
saw it Stargate Atlantis was in San
Francisco Bay
The Wraith was still about but the show
had ended we were originally going to
get a director DVD movie Stargate
Extinction which would have tied up that
those loose ends
and we were going to get a six season
the Stargate Atlantis as well but but
due to mgm's bankruptcy all of Stargate
got canned take a look at Stargate
Universe the rug was pulled on Stargate
Universe just as it was getting good
[Music]
foreign
season one was very very slow a lot a
lot of people were really into season
one yes it was a struggle to watch but
it was still Stargate season two was
getting so much better there was a much
better storyline and I feel the
Curiosity of what Stargate is was really
really honed in in season two of
Stargate Universe but but it was
canceled on a massive Cliffhanger and
one of the things I know about people
who watch this channel other Stargate
fans Etc is the one thing people are
crying out for more than anything is we
want a conclusion to Stargate Universe
Mark Fergus of penguin and Parker has
been doing lots and lots of meetings
with MGM and Amazon and has put forward
his ideas and if he gets the show and he
becomes a showrunner and if they
announce something then we are going to
get that conclusion and that has excited
me that it's excited a lot of you guys
as well whilst I would love there to be
a Stargate movie something on the big
screen that everyone can get on board
with and everyone can get excited about
and just grow the Stargate fan base I
feel like you need to finish off what
was left because the actors in Stargate
Universe Stargate Atlantis even some of
the actors from Stargate sg1 are still
young enough that they could appear in a
new show and then moving forward you
could start a new story and bring in new
characters
new places to visit New ships new
antagonists and things like that they
could essentially wrap up everything
that's happened with sg1 tie it into the
overall story and then kind of do a
reboot of a brand new story kind of like
what they did with Stargate Universe
where it was a brand new story in an
entirely different part of the universe
but it still made sense within within
the Canon of Stargate once they've done
that they could then potentially move
into making it much grander and doing a
movie as I said there are many arguments
for Kickstart and a new franchise with a
movie yes there is money involved and
Money Talks but I think if you kept it
as a TV series at least uh full kick
starting people would be way more
excited because because people who want
a conclusion to the previous two shows I
mean sg1 kind of already had a
conclusion but for slug Atlantis and
Stargate Universe the hype around that
would be insane I think even more also
than if they were to just announce a
Stargate movie because the fear people
have with a movie is it's going to be a
reboot and no one wants a reboot people
want something that's going to continue
the story that we know and love so my
argument wholeheartedly is please Amazon
if you are to Kickstart a new franchise
kick start it with a series conclude the
things that we want concluded and then
move into new stories and new and new
ideas that you might have for the
franchise push the franchise forward but
please give us the answers that we want
what is your opinion movie or TV
franchise let me know in the comment
section down below and as I said Jay
will be making a video arguing that a
movie would be better opposed to a TV
series on Thursday so keep an eye out
for that so come and see me on Thursday
when I will explain to you once again
while Matt is talking rubbish and that
he really should shut up I will explain
to you why we no only want a movie but
we need a movie if you are new to the
channel make sure you hit like And
subscribe and press the Bell
notification so you don't miss a single
video also consider becoming one of our
patreons by going to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you'll get access
to videos way earlier than anyone else
you don't even have to watch the adverts
and you'll be supporting the channel
thank you so much for watching my name's
Matt and I will see you next week
thank you